m
ce ratage ya pas non plus c'est vraiment
non plus
cabu s'est réveillé il est avec nous
aujourd'hui c'est gentil devenir cas vu
c'était ce qu'est un tel courrier de 2,2
d'enfants qui veulent savoir ce que tu
es qui tue est parce qu enfin quand tu
traiteras très timide et tu ne pars
jamais toi alors aujourd'hui tube loca
timidité et on parle de toi bon avec la
sava les voit pas choisi parce qu'en
fait quand il me dit mido si tu sais que
nos amis nous demande souvent comment de
via ton dessinateur
alors toi comment tu as commencé c'est
pour faire le métier que je fais il n'y
a pas d'école mais enfin
j'ai commencé par faire un journal au
lycée ils ont tout de suite des départs
tu voulais
tu dessines est tout le temps c'est
traditionnel codage de 12 ans j'avais
envie d'être de faire des dessins dans
les journaux dans les journaux oui parce
que quand j'étais petit il y avait pas
encore de télévision toi enfin c'était
les débuts de la télévision
alors j'ai fait un petit journal où
j'étais rédacteur en chef je distribuais
je le vendais 3
je faisais tout et je faisais une page
de dessins pour passer mes dessins et
après à 15 ans 15 ans et demi je suis
allé voir le rédacteur en chef d'un
journal régional qui s'appelle l'union
de reims et ils m'ont passé des dessins
au début un par semaine puis après j'en
avais presque chaque jour j'ai appris à
dessiner la jal et au conseil municipal
je faisais des caricatures déjà déjà 15
oui aucun sens
alors appartement où t'es où t'es un
prix mais tu tues tu vois tes défauts tu
vois mieux tes défauts parce que dessins
sont réduits tu vois c'est mieux
présenter cause donc faut quand même
avertir nos jeunes amis que ce n'est pas
en faisant tout de suite une bande
dessinée que
non parce que pour avant de publier un
album faut être publiée dans les
journaux
bah ça c'est
ces chemins oui alors moi je sais que
beaucoup d'amis à moi sont curieux sert
à montrer ça tient devant la tête que tu
as vu quand tu étais petit
alors voila tu étais là t'as quel âge
avait 5 ans la cinq ans petit est mignon
tu étais tu t'es qu'un écheveau non non
j'étais blanc c'est vraiment ça c'est la
tête qu'on connaît un peu plus jeune du
parthénon et tahiti minutes et je te
militaire ces fiches vocaux le plus
mauvais souvenir de ma vie pilar mme
koné ça c'était une émission sur le
canada rappelle yves et les indiens sur
le pays oui les légendes indiennes
oui car j'aimerais montrer comme ça
c'est dans tes débuts ça c'est pas les
tout premiers cela dit c'était des boues
j'aimerais un petit peu ce que tu
dessines et déjà c'était peut-être plus
précis que maintenant je trouve plus
appliqués les appliquer oui j'étais plus
du maladroit plus tôt
moi j'aime bien les premiers duduche
s'est senti quand en 1963 19 et 22 en
cours ça nous rajeunit pas alors on
reparlera de trappes de thatcher et des
quelques petites critiques at oui on
pourrait avoir les deux
tout à l'air tout à l'heure quand matin
nous allons regarder chaoui gros dos et
pac-man si tu veux bien
il est d'accord alors on sait chouette